ROSE: Welcome, everybody.
My name is Gideon Rose.
I am the editor of Foreign Affairs, and I'm
delighted to be able to welcome you to another
Foreign Affairs Live, this one on new emerging
markets, which is based on our package in
the Jan-Feb issue, "Where to Bet Now."
Let me just say a little word about this,
because some people might say, gee, what is
Foreign Affairs doing talking about emerging
markets?
And this is not your kind of wheelhouse.
And why are you in there at all?
And for 90 years, we've been purveying a steady
stream of serious expert commentary on a whole
range of subjects.
Our best known subject matter has always been,
of course, U.S. foreign policy and grand strategy
and security studies and diplomacy, but we've
done a lot of other things, as well, and certainly
the original vision was one that essentially
covered the world.
And in today's world, our feeling is that,
if it's important, we should be covering it,
and we should be covering it with the same
kind of seriousness intellectually, the same
kind of practical relevance, and the same
kind of accessible presentation that we've
always brought to other kinds of things.
And so whether it's emerging markets, whether
it's technology, which is the subject of the
lead package in our March-April issue, whether
it's energy markets, which are the subject
of our -- the lead package in May-June, we're
going to be doing not just all the things
we used to do and better than ever, but we're
going to be tackling whatever else is out
there that is important, the trends that are
driving the world that are important to our
clientele, and bringing to it the same kind
of expertise and accessibility and authority
that we've brought to the things that we're
traditionally better known for.
So that's, if you're ever wondering why we're
doing this kind of thing, expect more of the
-- expect more of this.
But it's not so much a new departure, as it
is an expansion of the franchise to all things
that matter.
So with that, everybody knows that, despite
the recent week or so in which the public
seemed to pick up on it for the first time,
or in a big way, the major emerging markets
that have been hot over the last several years
have started to come undone.
The BRICs are crumbling.
Some of the major countries that were doing
very well a few years ago, you could throw
a dart -- you know, throw a dart at a dartboard
and do well by investing in the developing
world, that's not true now.
That said, there are some green shoots out
there.
There are some very promising stories.
And if you look at a stagnating Europe, a
slowing China, a muddling forward in a positive,
but not particularly exciting way U.S., we
thought that it was very important that -- and
worth time -- to essentially take a look at
some of the newer emerging markets, the hotter
developing countries that people hadn't focused
on as much, and say, gee, where are places
that over the next several years are going
to be interesting to watch and worthwhile
to -- to maybe bet on.
And what we did was we went out and found
sort of absolutely top experts in each of
those countries to present to us honestly
and straightforwardly, not in a kind of touting
way, not in a national champion kind of way,
just what are the secrets of this country's
success to date?
What are the reasons to be optimistic about
it in the world that's going forward?
And what are the challenges that have to be
overcome?
What are the walls of worry that have to be
climbed?
Because, of course, every place has all sorts
of problems that need to be overcome.
This is our attempt to basically dip into
sort of global economic forecasting.
And without further ado, let me introduce
our panel, and we'll get right to it.
So, Marcus Noland is the executive vice president
and director of studies at the Peterson Institute
for International Economics, and he's going
to talk about South Korea.
Mitchell Orenstein is the chair of the political
science department at Northeastern University,
and he's going to talk to us about Poland.
And Steve Cook is the Hasib Sabbagh Senior
Fellow for Middle Eastern Studies at the Council.
He's going to talk to us about Turkey.
David Dombey -- sorry, yeah, Dombey wrote
the piece in the package on Turkey.
He couldn't be with us tonight, but Steve
is not only a good friend, has written for
us on Turkey many times, and is going to be
the Turkey expert tonight.
I urge you to look at the whole package...
COOK: And Dombey's taller than me.
ROSE: ... to look at the whole -- whole package,
and Mexico is obviously one of the most interesting
countries, and Shannon's piece on that is
quite good.
And the two pieces on ASEAN, sort of the archipelagoes
and the mainland one, highlight countries
that people haven't really paid all that much
attention to outside pure regionalists and
are also worth a close look.
Without further ado, so, Marcus, why is Korea
in this?
And why are we -- what are the reasons to
be excited and/or worried about Korea?
NOLAND: Well, I think the reason that Korea
is in it tonight is that Korea is the premier
development success story of the last 50 years.
Fifty years ago, South Korea was poorer than
Mozambique or Bolivia or Ghana.
And today, it's richer than Spain and New
Zealand.
It was the first non-OECD -- excuse me, non-G-7
or -G-8 country to host the G-20 summit.
It was the first Asian country to host the
G-20 summit.
But as remarkable as its economic transformation
has been, its political transformation was
arguably even more stunning.
In a period of a decade, from the late 1980s
to the late 1990s, they went from a military
dictator to his hand-picked general who was
elected successor to an elected civilian centrist
politician to electing a political dissident
who a previous leader had tried to kill as
president of the country.
And it was a country that hosted the second
nuclear summit and now a Korean national former
foreign minister is secretary general of the
United Nations.
So it is a country that has had stunning success
in economics, has had success in politics,
and those successes are now being recognized
at the international level.
When Jonathan Tepperman first approached me
about participating in this project, I actually
told him I wasn't really sure, you know, I
should do it, because in some ways, the talk
about Korea as an emerging market is a bit
of an anachronism.
Korea today has a per capita income of $25,000.
It's a trillion-dollar economy.
Now, it is a very open economy.
Exports plus imports exceed national income.
Trade ratio is more than 100 percent.
And that means that South Korea is unusually
vulnerable to shocks.
And in that sense, it is a riskier economy
in which to invest than, say, the United States
or Japan or Canada.
So in that sense, there is this kind of aspect
that it is -- it has not completely made the
transition into a kind of emerged economy.
There is still an emerging economy aspect
to it.
That said, in the last couple weeks, when
investor concerns have really been roiling
markets, the impact on South Korea has been
nothing, for example, compared to the impact
on Turkey.
So it seems like investors are really putting
it in a different basket.
Challenges moving forward is that growth is
slowing.
For the first time in history, trend growth
is probably something on the order of 3 percent
to 3.5 percent, which actually means it's
growing slower than the world average for
the first time.
And South Koreans put a lot of demands on
their government, so the government has recently
begun -- this month announced that they're
going to have a three-year plan.
They've established some very ambitious goals.
They want to have per capita income get from
$25,000 to $30,000.
They want to raise the rate of growth to 40
percent.
They want to raise the labor participation
rate to 70 percent, which would imply substantial
increases in labor participation by women
and young people.
So it's a very ambitious set of targets.
They haven't actually released the plan.
The plan is supposed to come out this coming
month.
But they've identified three strategies that
they want to use.
The first is, there's an emphasis on building
a more competitive economy.
And what exactly does that mean?
South Korea's been really successful economically,
but part of that success has been that it
is a kind of unbalanced economy.
Very, very large conglomerates account for
a lot of the economy.
And while the manufacturing sector has obviously
done very well -- everybody in this room is
familiar with Samsung and Hyundai -- the service
sector has really lagged and is highly regulated.
And in particular, there's a whole plethora
of state-owned enterprises or government-sponsored
enterprises or parastatals -- I'm not exactly
sure how you'd describe them all -- but there
is a sense that they can operate not exactly
conforming to market rules.
And, in fact, there's a lot of concern about
the debts that these organizations are running
up.
So the first part of the plan is try to level
out the playing field to have a more competitive
economy.
Second is an emphasis on creativity.
I suppose everybody in this room is familiar
with, you know, "Gangnam Style" and, you know,
the whole boom in South Korean cinema.
And so that's kind of a code word for shifting
away from manufacturing and towards services.
How you do that is not so clear.
And, finally, there's an emphasis on rebalancing
away from external demand to domestic demand.
But, again, if you actually listen to what
President Park Geun-hye has been saying over
the last month, she's actually been talking
about really ways of milking external demand
a little more, not such clear ideas on how
to shift towards domestic demand, although
the National Assembly is bringing forward
some expenditures.
Final thing.
So far, everything I've said is pretty conventional.
I mean, the Korean story is outstanding, of
course.
But it's all kind of comprehensible.
There is one thing that sets South Korea apart,
that is the world's largest contingent liability,
North Korea.
And one of the really curious things in the
last month, not only in South Korea, but then
at Davos, President Park has been talking
about unification.
And she's been talking about unification in
very positive terms.
She's described it as a jackpot, as a bonanza.
Now, personally, I think there are many reasons
to look forward to Korean unification.
I mean, I look forward to the disappearance
of the current North Korean regime.
Stimulus to the South Korean economy is not
high on my list of reasons about why I am
looking forward to that.
But between interesting developments in the
economy and potentially enormous developments
with respect to North Korea, I think South
Korea remains a very interesting and exciting
country.
ROSE: OK.
My son is 13 and is having his bar mitzvah
in two weeks, and you can tell that Korea
has come of age because Psy, the "Gangnam
Style" pop star, is actually on the New York
bar mitzvah circuit.
And you can check on Instagram.
He is available.
You can have Psy do "Gangnam Style" at your
child's bar mitzvah, if you're prepared to
pony up, which is something that I don't think
was ever the case in previous kinds of things.
True story.
Mitch, you know, 20 years ago, the idea that
Poland would be featured at a panel like this
would have been laughable.
And 70 years ago, there wasn't a Poland.
So explain how Poland went -- as in the title
of your piece -- from tragedy to triumph?
ORENSTEIN: Yeah, well, thank you so much.
I wanted to -- the previous speaker, Marcus
Noland, drew a kind of interesting contrast
between South Korea and North Korea.
And as I was writing the piece, I thought
about Foreign Affairs' trajectory that you
mentioned and the way that it tries to encompass
-- I mean, its tradition is geopolitics, and
trying to bring that geopolitical angle into
thinking about the economy.
And so I was thinking, well, what are some
interesting contrasts you could draw with
Poland?
And I was thinking, well, you know, maybe
you could compare Poland to South Korea and
have Belarus as their sort of North Korea,
you know?
I decided not to go that route...
ROSE: Good choice.
ORENSTEIN: ... but -- but I will bring up
another contrast that's extremely relevant
today, which is Ukraine.
As we look at Ukraine -- and I know a lot
of us in this room are following the events
in Ukraine -- one's looking at the past of
European politics, that one's looking at a
country riven by serious geopolitical fault
lines, one in which the politics are extremely
tenuous as a result, one in which the economic
progress has, therefore, been extremely muted
in comparison to Poland.
So when people ask me about my piece, which
is very bullish, very optimistic on Poland,
and they say, why are you so optimistic about
Poland?
I say, well, look at Ukraine.
And indeed, this argument came up, as I understand,
in Davos recently.
There were a couple tweets that I picked up
from Davos showing a nice chart of the trajectory
of Poland's GDP growth, which has doubled
in proportion to E.U.
average, whereas Ukraine has more or less
stagnated for the last 20 years.
And the result is now that you have a GDP
in Poland which had been quite similar to
Ukraine historically is now about three times
on a per capita purchasing power parity basis.
So...
ROSE: Do the Poles make Ukrainian jokes?
NOLAND: They probably do, yeah.
They probably do.
Although I think today they have largely a
very hopeful outlook on Ukraine.
So Poland is a country that was in that type
of Eastern European past, that had extreme
political turmoil.
It has an enormously tragic history.
One can't step far in Poland without encountering
that sort of history on one side or another.
And yet it's managed to overcome that in the
last 20 years to become one of the most successful
economies in the world.
It's now the 20th-largest economy -- or 24th-largest
economy in the world.
It's on its way to being the 20th-largest.
It's a country which has utterly changed its
geopolitical fate.
It's no longer a Ukraine.
It's a Poland.
And it has really entered -- it's on the verge
of entering the core of the European Union.
It will need to adopt the euro at some point
to make that happen.
But it's a core -- it's becoming a core economy
of Europe, just as Britain is sort of moving
out of that sort of status.
So how did it do this?
Well, I think part of the answer -- there's
a number of answers one could give to that,
but I think that one should go back to geopolitics
to really understand the core of it.
One of the key answers I give in the piece
is that Poland has become a Western nation
by virtue of the fact that its borders were,
in fact, moved at the end of the Second World
War.
I had a nice little chart to show this, but
I think a lot of people know the basic outlines.
Poland existed several hundred miles to the
east up until 1945.
It was an Eastern-facing country, a country
with an Eastern empire.
In fact, when it got its nationhood in 1918,
practically the first thing it did is keep
marching further east and try to grab some
more territory away from the Soviet Union
in 1920 to 1922, at the time of the civil
war in the Soviet Union.
And after the Molotov-Ribbentrop Pact, which
took most of eastern Poland into the Soviet
Union, Poland was compensated at the end of
the war with a whole lot of German territory
which was seized.
Those are the big areas of Pomerania, Silesia
and East Prussia.
And so the map of Poland today is -- I want
to say -- more than a third former German
territory.
And I have one line that I thought was going
to be controversial in the piece saying, you
know, Poland today is, to a large extent Germany
inhabited by Poles.
And that, of course, came about because of
dramatic expulsions, extremely devastating
expulsions of people, where some millions
of Germans -- say, I think, 5 million or 6
million Germans were expelled out of Poland
into Germany and 2 million or 3 million Poles
were expelled out of the Soviet -- the eastern
Polish territories, which are now Gud Lviv
(ph) and Vilnius, and move to the west, to
the emptied west of Poland.
That for Stalin was a great move.
It effectively punished the Germans after
the war.
It expanded the territory of the Soviet Union
and in a way punished the Poles, also.
But what I don't think he looked at, at the
time, and what's become evident now, is that
it made Poland a Western nation.
And where Poland had always vacillated, always
been a sort of marching ground for armies
in a sort of tug-of-war between Russia and
Germany, it effectively planted Poland in
this terrible history as firmly in the German
sphere of influence.
And that's where it's come to at this moment.
So the reason to invest in Poland, the reason
to look at Poland as a serious world economy
is because of its extremely tight relationship
with Germany.
When you look at sort of the European story
-- you mentioned we talk a lot about European
stagnation, obviously the country that's not
stagnating and is actually doing quite well
in all of this is Germany.
Germany -- the German economy is doing great.
The strategy that...
(UNKNOWN): Testing.
This isn't working.
ORENSTEIN: ... they're pushing for the rest
of Europe is one that's really working for
Germany.
And it's also working for Poland.
Poland, in contrast to other emerging markets,
has just had its growth outlook upgraded,
so it's now looking at 3 percent growth or
4 percent growth this year.
Why?
Well, because Poland has become a -- has become
a low-cost platform, low-cost, high-quality
platform for production of European, but largely
German goods.
This is really across-the-board, if you look
at any industry, but the primary one is the
auto industry, where companies like Volkswagen
employ thousands of workers in Poland, producing
all sorts of German automobiles, from trucks
to cars to luxury cars, not just cheap cars.
Hugo Boss, the fashion-maker, makes a lot
of its products -- mainly its shoes -- in
Poland.
MAN, the bus-maker, makes its stuff in Poland.
And now they're starting to employ nearly
as many workers in Poland as they are in Germany.
In fact, one recent analysis by one of the
major investment banks showed that nearly
-- I think was 30 percent or 40 percent of
Poland's exports to Germany end up as Germany's
exports to the rest of the world.
So those German exports are including a huge
component of Poland.
So in this, it's interesting that Poland was
able to pull this off at a time when China
was rising in the global economy.
And obviously, China became Eastern Europe,
and Poland in the foremost their main competitor.
You know, they were trying to attract capital
at the same time as Asia, Asian competitors,
like South Korea and China are taking off.
And so they had to really prove that they
had a value proposition.
So what was that value proposition?
The value proposition was that you could make
goods cheaper in Poland than you could in
China, not every good, not very lightweight
goods, but heavy industry, things that have
substantial transport costs involved with
them, such as automotive, such as white goods,
where actually -- have become actually cheaper
to produce in Poland than to produce in China.
And that's really, I think, the -- you know,
the sort of bottom line.
In addition to that, of course, you have a
much more stable political environment by
virtue of the E.U.
You have the massive E.U.
investment in Poland, which is building the
highways, the autobahn that Poland never had,
correcting a lot of their infrastructure problems,
tying them in much more closely to Western
Europe.
And so you have the political thing and then,
of course, the proximity, which is that a
German manager can, you know, drive over to
the factory in Poland, take a look, walk around,
see it.
So you have -- you have a whole system which
is much more monitorable and much more easily
compatible with European ways of doing things
than a factory in China.
So I would say that Poland, for these reasons,
for its political stability, which is rooted
in the geopolitical situation, for the strong
linkages, the close ties, the way it's embraced
Germany is really an economy that's going
to be on the upswing for quite a long time,
and probably will do better over the next
10 or 20 years than the forecasts even think.
ROSE: What are the challenges?
ORENSTEIN: Well, the challenges, I think,
are still political.
So some of you may -- some people will note
that the current government is on the verge
of losing its majority its parliament.
It's facing elections where it's uncertain
to win.
And as -- like a lot of countries in Europe
right now, the far-right or the more populist
right in Poland is rising.
And they typically have a more populist economic
platform, to some extent.
They're more welfarist, in particular.
And people always raise questions about this
and wonder, you know, what's going to -- what
the effect is on the economy.
And you may remember the disputes about the
Kaczynski twins and their sort of statements
about Europe and others.
So that kind of politics could emerge as dominant
in Poland again.
My personal view on it, though, is that it's
probably not going to have such a huge effect
on the economy, which is why I remain optimistic.
Obviously, geopolitical turmoil, you know,
that -- unresolved in Ukraine or, you know,
the relations with Russia are, you know, potentially
issues.
But I guess those are really the main potential
blockages, that there's something that takes
it off this train that's zooming towards Europe.
ROSE: Steve, a couple of years ago, Turkey
would have been a no-brainer for something
like this.
In fact, it was -- there were people who suggested
adding it to the BRICs, or various kinds of
-- you know, almost moving it up into the
super-stratosphere in developing economies.
It's cooled off a little bit, and there's
political turmoil.
So what are the -- why did Turkey do so well?
And where is it going now?
And what are the challenges?
COOK: Thanks, Gideon.
And thanks for including me in this, because
I did not contribute to this package, but
have been thinking and writing about Turkey,
including for Foreign Affairs, for a while.
I also want to thank you.
For the last 10 minutes, I'm sorry, I didn't
pay any attention.
I've been replaying my bar mitzvah with Psy
in it.
Totally the oddest thing I could -- anyway...
ROSE: Other ones this year have include Lorde
and Imagine Dragons, all on the Instagram
circuit.
It's really ridiculous.
COOK: In any event, look, you know, Turkey
-- and you're absolutely right.
In the last decade, Turkey certainly would
have been a no-brainer.
And I think a lot of people tried to work
the T into the BRICs.
And the Turks certainly wanted the T in there
and often talked about how they should be
included among those countries.
And I think that the genesis of the kind of
great 2000s Turkish economic boom goes back
to the economic crisis of 2000 and 2001, when
a government prior to the Justice and Development
Party, before Tayyip Erdogan came to power,
undertook some very serious and painful reforms.
Those reforms are authored by Kemal Dervis,
our colleague from the Brookings Institution,
and despite some expectations, after the Justice
and Development Party came to power in 2002
that they would pursue a populist economic
policies and not stick to the very kind of
stringent conditions that the IMF had imposed,
they were basically responsible stewards of
the economy.
So take that, they were able to instill confidence
in investors by sticking to an IMF program,
add it to a large, young population, a country
that does have a manufacturing base.
Talking about automotive manufacturing, if
you're going to buy a Ford in Europe, it was
manufactured in Turkey.
Then you have location.
Turkey sits at an important location, access
both Central Asia, Eurasia, the Middle East,
Europe, the Balkans, the Eastern Mediterranean,
extraordinarily important.
And over the course of this decade, you had
the rise of new Turkish entrepreneurs, these
kind of fearless entrepreneurs which show
up everywhere around the world wanting to
trade.
I remember just by an anecdote, I was having
dinner with one of these representatives from
one of the Turkish trade associations.
And he was aware of my interest in Egypt and
Egyptian politics and Egyptian economy.
And he said, oh, we have a very small investment
in Egypt.
I said, oh, really?
You know, how many?
He said, oh, well, we employ 70,000 people
in Egypt.
I thought that was pretty extraordinary.
So you have the combination of, I think, good
economic stewardship, a young and growing
population, a manufacturing base, to some
extent, good location, and then this kind
of bubble about, you know, Turkey as a liberalizing,
democratizing country.
I mean, one of the advantages that Turkey
really had in the 2000s was that it wasn't
Turkey in the 1990s, where you had a series
of unstable governments that didn't make sense.
You had a coup d'etat.
The Turks, you know, kind of bristle at the
idea that it was a coup, but they call it
the blanc (ph) coup, the postmodern coup.
The fact of the matter is, is that the military
pushed a government out of power, produced
a significant amount of political instability.
Tayyip Erdogan and AKP come to power in 2002
and 2003.
And you suddenly don't have the need for coalition
governments.
You have a strong leader.
And the AKP, different from previous governments,
looked out to the world.
This was the party, this was the government
that was going to bring Turkey to the world.
Turkey historically had been very insular,
inward-looking, a kind of prickly nationalism.
Foreign investment was there, but not in the
kind of way then when the AKP opened up the
country.
I think the reason why Turkey has cooled off
is because, despite all the great promise
and these factors that have led to -- that
led to the great, you know, boom of the 2000s,
is that, one, the country's largely dependent
on financing a current account deficit through
foreign investment.
And that's essentially hot money.
Turkey has no energy resources to speak of
and must import all of its gas, and the only
way to finance that is through foreign investment.
Current account deficit is a structural problem.
Over the course of the decade, as Turks became
or believed that they were wealthier, you
saw -- again, nobody really wanted to talk
about it, but a consumer credit bubble emerging.
You know, I'd go back every couple months,
and you'd see a neighborhood transformed.
You'd see people who -- you know, friends
who told me that, you know, the guy -- the
neighbor didn't have a BMW two months ago,
now had a BMW.
There was clearly -- Turks were feeling wealthier
and starting to use credit when credit was
unavailable to them before.
You also had a very significant real estate
bubble.
I mean, if you look at the skyline of Istanbul,
it's been absolutely transformed over the
course of the last decade.
Some of that's real.
A lot of that has to do with crony capitalism
in Erdogan's Turkey and that the construction
industry has essentially become a vehicle
for patronage.
Add to that an illiberal turn in politics
that kind of exploded before everybody's eyes
during the Gezi Park protests this summer.
Add to that the corruption scandal that's
been rocking the country over the course of
the last month and you have the problems that
Turkey is confronting now, and along with
changes in -- or anticipated changes in Fed
policies, growth in the United States, people
are pulling their money out of Turkey as quickly
as possible.
And the lira took a massive nose dive.
The central bank last night, in an emergency
meeting, hiked the interest rates, seemed
to have stabilized the situation, and it was
something very, very important.
I wrote about this for FA.com a couple weeks
ago.
Something very important happened.
Erdogan had lobbied against this interest
rate hike.
He has been laying the groundwork for his
survival in this very difficult economic environment
since the summer by talking about the interest
rate lobby, the international bankers, Zionists,
Islamophobes.
I've been called every single one of these
things, by the way, by any number of Turks.
And he lobbied against it, but he said ultimately
he had no power to prevent it from happening.
To me, that was an -- that's a double-edged
sword, because I think in -- I think what
prevented, what put the break on Erdogan really
putting the screws to the central banker,
Erdem Basci, who, you know, many people were
holding out a hero for defying Erdogan, but
who previously had been seen as kind of a
-- you know, too close to the prime minister.
I think had it not been this massive fear
of what might happen had they not hiked interest
rates, Erdogan might have gotten his way.
And I think that what that speaks to -- and
I think this is a fundamental weakness in
Turkey -- is perverse institutions, either
weak or perverse institutions, in which at
crisis moments, political leaders either use
them for their own non-democratic agendas
or go around them.
And I think that, had there not been this
massive, massive fear about what might happen
had there not been an interest rate hike,
it would have been business as usual and Erdogan
would have applied as much pressure on the
central bank as possible not to have the interest
rate hike.
ROSE: So are you completely bearish?
Or is there any bullish aspect to it?
COOK: You know, it's hard to see where -- you
know, there are -- you know, there have been
some, you know, positive -- there was positive
investment in real things in Turkey.
There was a recent big investment in the dairy
industry, which seems like the right thing,
but a lot of the investment has not been towards
productive, real kind of investment.
I think that, you know, when Turkey comes
out on the other end, there has -- you will
see that, you know, the AKP record is not
all bad.
There's been significant improvement in infrastructure,
airports built, high-speed railways, highways,
and so on and so forth.
But basically, this economy has been, you
know, jacked up by fiscal policy and hot money
and reputation for a government that's stable,
and suddenly it doesn't look as stable as
it once was.
I'm not talking about, you know, Egypt instability,
but we're talking about a significant amount
of political ferment for the foreseeable future,
and I think that's what the markets are responding
to.
I don't see a way out.
Nobody's going to give up in this struggle
in Turkey, and I think it will -- there will
be iterations of this ongoing.
ROSE: It's funny.
You talked about the acronym and trying to
get Turkey into the BRICs.
When we were putting together the package,
we thought about an acronym, and I actually
came up with one that was our temporary internal
name for the package, which was the GEMs,
the growing emerging markets.
And my staff ultimately vetoed that and said
the acronyms are stupid, don't do acronyms,
and so forth and so -- so, fine, we didn't.
OK.
Well, this has been great.
Let me take one question from the chair before
I turn it over to our members and participants.
If we had Shannon here, if we had Karen Brooks
here, who talked about, you know, the Philippines,
we talked about Mexico, one of the questions
we'd be asking is about the role of leadership.
So you have Aquino in the Philippines or Pena
Nieto in Mexico who managed to turn their
countries around and pull off reforms that
their predecessors hadn't either been interested
in or able to.
Have leadership -- and I see that -- to a
certain extent, we see this in Turkey with
Erdogan playing a negative role, leadership
being important there, not just on the upside,
but then screwing it up.
In Poland and in South Korea, and to one extent
in Turkey, too, how much of a crucial variable
has personal leadership been in driving successes?
NOLAND: Well, in the case of South Korea,
South Korea has a form of government where
the president is quite strong, and so the
quality of leadership has made a big difference.
But I think it -- and I think that people
probably underestimated President Park Geun-hye,
including the North Koreans, and I think probably
part of this was related to the fact she's
a woman.
And she's turned out to be a tougher, kind
of more committed, harder, you know -- she's
a more forceful and stronger leader than I
think some people expected.
But I think another aspect of it -- and I
was really reminded of this listening to Steve
-- if you compare South Korea and Turkey right
now, there are -- there are two big differences,
the reason why Turkey's gotten hit with this
financial -- emerging financial crisis and
South Korea really hasn't.
First of all, South Korea is running a trade
surplus; Turkey's running a deficit.
But the more important point is that Turkey
-- a lot of that deficit is -- what you had
in Turkey was you had Turkish banks borrowing
from European banks in euros short and lending
to construction firms in Anatolia and so forth
in lira long.
And that's created both term and currency
mismatch.
And that's very dangerous.
And a lot of people initially were concerned
that the problem would emerge in Europe, that
if something happened in Europe and the European
banking system contracted, they'd cut the
Turks off and Turks would be in trouble.
It hasn't worked out that way, but that created
a dangerous situation.
In South Korea, South Korea got into some
trouble in the global financial crisis.
The won fell by 45 percent.
They were subject to a sudden stop.
And one of the things the South Korean financial
regulators recognized was that South Korean
banks and South Korean firms were doing things
to indirectly create the same sorts of mismatches,
and they stepped in and put a stop to it.
And so the point I would emphasize is, the
thing about South Korea, South Korea, like
any other country in the world, has the capacity
to screw things up.
But one of the things that's really striking
about South Korea is they learn from their
mistakes.
And -- and you have not only the quality of
leadership at the presidency level, but you
have a quality of leadership in governing
institutions more broadly that they change,
they adjust, and so the financial regulatory
authorities in Korea now act with greater
prudential activism than they did several
years ago.
And that's -- it's helped them in this emerging
situation the last couple of weeks.
ROSE: Mitch, has leadership played a particularly
significant role in Poland?
ORENSTEIN: Yeah, I mean, this is a great question,
a very controversial one with regard to Poland.
There's a number of leaders, economic leaders
who claim all the credit for Poland's success.
And I tend to be rather skeptical of those
claims.
But one wouldn't want to say that leadership's
unimportant.
I think like in South Korea, where you're
talking about leadership goes very deep, right,
it's not only at the top level, but we're
talking about the bureaucracies, we're talking
about multiple decision-makers.
Poland's a country that's gone through -- I
can't even count the number of governments
since 1989.
I mean, I think it's like dozens, you know,
or at least over a dozen, anyway.
It's a government where -- it's a country
where the reformist government that was put
in, in 1990 lasted only about a year and then
was succeeded by a very populist right-wing
government.
It was succeeded by a left-wing government.
It was succeeded by another liberal government,
by another populist government, and it keeps
on going.
A lot of political change.
So what's interesting about Poland's transformation
is that it's been carried forward by the entire
political class.
This -- remember, this happened -- this sort
of thing used to happen in the United States,
too, right, where there was like a bipartisan
sort of, you know, agenda going forward?
Well, Poland has that.
And what I would call that is not leadership.
I would call that social consensus.
I would call that maybe an elite consensus
that there's only one direction to be going,
and that direction is towards the West.
Whether you like it or not, whether you're
comfortable or not with all aspects of it,
it's been widely recognized in Poland that
that is the game in town and that you'd better
play it.
And I think that makes it -- that's why I
talk about this in a more geopolitical space.
Why did that consensus emerge?
I think that's the thing that's been missing
throughout Polish history.
Poland's famous for what's called the liberum
veto.
Back in the 1500s, Poland was organized in
a quasi-democratic arrangement of nobility,
but any one person could veto whatever the
policy was of the day, and that was what ultimately
led to the demise of Poland as a state.
How did this country develop such a strong
consensus on Westernization, where its neighbors,
its near neighbors, Ukraine has not, Belarus
has not?
And I think it had to do with a specific historical
juncture they were at and a sense among the
broad elite that they couldn't mess this up,
it was a unique opportunity to get to the
West, and they were going to do that.
So I think that one should look skeptically
on claims of particular individual leaders
who claim a great deal of credit for this.
I see many, many people there who can claim
a lot of credit.
ROSE: Steve, a few words about leadership
in Turkey, pro and con?
COOK: You know, I would -- I would agree with,
you know, Mitchell's last point that, you
know, you have to be skeptical of these claims
about a single leader.
After all, as I said, many of the reforms
that put Turkey on the path of growth in 2000
were put in place by Kemal Dervis and a previous
government.
But there is something about Tayyip Erdogan.
First of all, he is the best politician I
have ever seen this side of Bill Clinton.
He just has this innate ability to connect
with Turks and understands what Turks -- what
makes Turks tick.
And it is absolutely magnetic.
And, you know, it's -- it took that kind of
leadership, that kind of political skill,
I think, to undertake some of the really difficult
reforms that, particularly in the political
sphere, that led to this decade of stability.
It took Tayyip Erdogan to bring the military
to heel.
Now, it hasn't ended up as well as it might
have, but it took this type of personality
to kind of wrench Turkey out of that malaise
and that instability of the 1990s.
The question is, now has the time passed for
Erdogan?
Because he now is creating his own distortions,
because of a certain arrogance of power, because
of concern -- starting back as far as 2007,
concern that the system was going to strike
back.
He has resorted to a series of authoritarian
measures to establish control and institutionalize
the power of the party.
That has now clearly caught up with them,
and that's why the markets are pricing all
of this risk into Turkey.
So he may have been appropriate, he may have
been necessary in the early 2000s and through
the first decade of the 21st century, but
the question is, is he the appropriate leader
to bring Turkey?
I don't know.
But, again, I'm skeptical of these, you know,
great man kind of arguments.
ROSE: OK.
At this point, let's bring all of you into
the conversation.
So stand, state your name after I call on
you, and wait for the microphone.
This is on-the-record, unlike usual Council
sessions, so let's start out over here.
Yes?
QUESTION: I'm Glen Fukushima with the Center
for American Progress.
I have a question for my friend, Marcus Noland.
Before I put my money into South Korea, I
have two questions.
Number one, is the contingent liability you
talked about, North Korea -- how would you
assess the impact of unification, say, over
the next 5 or 10 years with the case of Germany?
And what impact do you think that unification
will have on the South Korean economy, in
terms of investment?
And, second -- the second question is, when
I was in Davos at the World Economic Forum
last week, a number of the South Koreans there
expressed some real concern about the fact
that Korea is caught among the trilateral
giants of China, Japan and the United States.
The relationship with the United States is
going very well, but with Japan, with the
comfort women issue, with the Yasukuni Shrine,
with Dokdo Island, Takeshima Island, all these
history issues and territorial issues, that's
a real problem.
With China, there's closer economic relations,
but politically there's not necessarily consistency.
So how do you see South Korea navigating among
these three giants?
NOLAND: So how long are we going to go?
Two hours?
OK, on the first question, Korean unification
would -- OK, assuming it all went smoothly,
didn't involve detonation of nuclear devices
or anything like that, if you just -- a very
nice, comfortable, you know, East German-style
collapse, right, no mass violence, the Korean
case would be much bigger and more daunting
that the German case.
North Korea is much larger relative to South
Korea than East Germany was to West Germany.
It is my poorer relative to South Korea than
East Germany was relative to West Germany.
It's probably a more screwed up, distorted
economy and has a -- you know, all due respect
to the Stasi, even a more screwed-up political
culture than East Germany.
So this will be a big deal.
People like me who model this, we need some
sort of end point to kind of anchor our models.
So a typical way of modeling this is to say,
how much money would it take to raise North
Korean incomes to 60 percent of those of the
South, 60 percent being rough difference between
the poorest and richest U.S. state, rough
difference between the poorest and richest
South Korean province, until recently, roughly
different between the richest and poorest
parts of the E.U.?
And it turns out that -- you know, that depends
partly on how fast you can absorb new technology
and how many people migrate across the border
and so on and so forth.
But a rough ballpark estimate, plausible set
of parameters, it's going to cost more than
$1 trillion over, say, a 10-year period.
And that means that this transitional period
is going to be long, you're going to have
to do something about population influx control,
you're going to have to do something about
voting rights for the current residents of
North Korea, how you integrate them into the
political system.
So it's not going to be a walk in the park.
It could be really, really good for South
Korean construction companies, right?
There's going to be a lot of work.
Depending on how much of the money comes in
from abroad and how the exchange rate behaves,
it may not be so good for South Korean manufacturing
exercises.
So the bottom line is, if you're a South Korean
construction magnate with money to, you know,
invest in unification bonds, unification could
be very, very good for you.
If you're a blue-collar worker in a traded
goods sector, you know, manufacturing something
for export, and now you suddenly have to compete
against your cousins up north, absent some
compensatory policies, that could be a pretty
tough thing, leading to increased wealth and
income inequality.
The geopolitical point, yeah, I mean, South
Korea has a tough situation.
Right now, as you know, the relations with
Japan are fairly acrimonious.
What's interesting about South Korea in the
economic sphere, at least, is that the South
Koreans are using the kind of acrimony against
Japan to spur their own internal reforms.
I mean, high-level people, the finance minister,
the head of Korea development, have got up
in public and said things like, you know,
Japan's gone through two decades of nothing,
the third arrow of Abenomics is going to fail,
we don't want to do that, so we've got to
start structural reforms today, right now,
seriously.
So they use their rivalry with Japan as a
spur.
And the fact that it's gotten a little more
heated recently just means it's a better spur.
The other thing that's curious is this.
South -- the yen -- the Japanese yen has really
depreciated against the South Korean won.
And that's hurt South Korean manufacturers
who compete against the Japanese directly
or indirectly.
I've been struck by the Park government has
not ridden the yen down, that they have said,
no, we are going to do restructuring, we are
going to promote the service sector and creative
economy, we are going to shift demand towards
domestic demand and not rely so much on export
markets.
And thus far -- this may not -- if we have
this meeting in a year, I may not be able
to say this -- but thus far, they have abjured
the kind of quick fix of letting the won go
down.
Now, I know that doesn't get into all the
geopolitical issues you represented, but we've
got two other people here, and they want to
talk, too.
ROSE: Great, thank you.
I would say that we actually have a piece
on Korean unification in the May-June issue
coming up that will be a look at sort of how
it might play out, what its effects might
be, and so forth, so look for that one.
Yes, over here.
QUESTION: I'm Mitzi Wertheim with the Naval
Postgraduate School.
I want you to look into the future.
How do you think 3-D manufacturing is going
to affect all of these economies?
Frankly, it scares the devil out of me, but
anyway.
I mean, I go to these meetings and listen
to mercs talk about they won't have any jobs
because all the 3-D creation will be done
at home and we won't have to transport anything.
ROSE: Are any of you up on digital fabrication
and could you speak authoritatively to that
point?
NOLAND: I think it's like Clint Eastwood said
in one of those movies.
A man's got to know his limitations.
(LAUGHTER)
ROSE: You know, it's interesting...
ORENSTEIN: I think you exceeded mine.
ROSE: The next issue has a lot of stuff on
tech in it, including stuff on the Internet
of things, by -- one of the co-authors is
Neil Gershenfeld, who wrote about digital
fabrication.
And this was actually a subject at Davos that
was talked about a lot.
And the question about employment and machines
and are we in a second machine age, and if
so, what's the future, it's actually fascinating.
One of the most interesting discussions that
I heard at Davos was an off-site dinner in
which Fareed Zakaria and Martin Wolf nearly
came to blows about whether the -- whether
the U.S. slowness in employment, in terms
of the rebound, after the economy rebounded,
was a harbinger of a fundamentally new situation
in which there's going to be a lower employment
plateau and so forth, or whether it was just
lack of demand and whether the transition
to a new kind of economy will be like old
ones.
We're going to cover this kind of issue more.
Nobody actually -- Mitch, do you want to talk
about that one?
ORENSTEIN: I'll just say a couple words.
I mean, I can't -- I can't see it having an
enormous impact in Poland.
If you can figure out how to print a Volkswagen
Golf, then, you know, I guess I would be wrong
about that.
But I think we're probably a long ways away
from that.
I don't see us being able to print washing
machines.
And I neglected to mention, also, you know,
a lot of the industry, a lot of what's happening
there is, you know, call centers or back-office
support operations.
So my guess is that that won't necessarily
have an outsized impact on Poland.
It's going to be...
QUESTION: Near term.
ORENSTEIN: Yeah, near term, right, right,
as far as I can see, you know.
COOK: I'd say the same thing with regard to
Turkey, not knowing really anything about
digital fabrication, but I know two things,
one, the Turkish economy, you know, we're
talking about big construction-type of things,
cars, you know, infrastructure projects, things
like that.
Until you can digitally fabricate an airport
runway, I thank the Turks are going to be
OK.
But I will say this.
For a country of Turkey's size and levels
of education, they are extraordinarily late
adopters when it comes to technology.
You know, there is no design fabrication software
work really happening in Turkey.
There is no kind of dynamic tech-type of sector
in Turkey at all.
So over time, they may well be left behind.
ROSE: Yes, over here.
You two.
Second row, then first row.
Yes, you first.
QUESTION: Diana Lady Dougan, Center for Strategic
and International Studies.
I wanted to pick on Steve for a moment because
of his expertise on both Egypt and Turkey.
And I know we're talking about emerging economies
or upper-end economies that were developing
countries, but the role of religion and the
military in both those countries, and -- and
also in Korea, I might add.
And by way of disclosure, I'm one of the producers
of a film called "The Square," and involved
in also post-production.
And I've been so struck by the demographics
of change.
And when we're looking at the aging of some
of these countries -- and I think Turkey average
age is about 29, and Egypt's is 25, but they
have a very highly educated workforce in Egypt,
and there's a lot going on right now.
But I guess I would like to, particularly
for you, but for others, to sort of extrapolate
where demographics are going to come out in
this.
And then, also, I can't help but think back
to some of your very articulate comments in
past years about how much the Egyptian military
is the capital of crony capitalism in Egypt
and the degree to which this exists elsewhere.
Thank you.
COOK: Thank you for the question.
I could spend the next three hours talking
about all of these things, so...
ROSE: You don't have the next three hours.
COOK: But I'm not going to -- I'm going to
get to the core of your question about demographics.
And it's funny.
When you think about it, you know, for years,
people have been talking about these demographic
issues, and it seemed like the dog that wouldn't
bark, but then suddenly it did bark.
And I think that, looking at Egypt and then
looking at Turkey, and looking at the Gezi
Park protests, and we cannot -- it was -- I
groan every time someone, you know, wanted
to make the connection between Gezi, is this
the Turkish Spring, as Tahrir Square was -- became
representative of the Arab Spring.
But both are, you know, predominantly young,
educated, mobilized, but unassimilated into
the political process type of movements.
But I think that they're somewhat different.
First, if there's anything that revolutionary
that has happened in Egypt over the course
of the three years, and not much, actually,
revolutionary has happened, is the fact that
you do have this young demographic that is
making demands on the political system and
articulating those demands in actually the
streets in a way that the authorities have
no real answer for, other than to employ authoritarian
measures.
That's not stable, because if their only answer
is to more violence, more force, and these
people remain, you know, brave in the face
of it, it's a recipe for continued political
instability.
The same kind of thing happened in Gezi on
a smaller scale.
Now, more and more people have come into the
Turkish political arena, but over time, over
this decade, fewer and fewer have been able
to contest it.
Now, with Gezi, it wasn't just an environmental
movement.
It wasn't just about the redevelopment of
this park off Taksim Square.
It was about police brutality, crony capitalism,
arrogance of power, the lack of access to
the political arena, the inability to contest
it, the inability of political parties, other
political parties to be effective.
These are -- you know, this is the new reality
in Turkey, as well.
The question is -- extrapolating now out -- in
both Egypt and Turkey is, how do these young,
mobilized people now translate that into the
formal political arena?
In Egypt, large numbers of them absolutely
reject the idea of formal politics and want
to stay outside of it.
Home is where the streets are.
The streets are where home is.
The street is where we've been most effective.
We will only be co-opted if we go inside.
In Turkey, they're still trying to figure
this out.
They are -- many of them, these ineffective
political parties that exist are trying to
co-opt them.
Just by way of anecdote, I met a group of
them, wealthy, young, mobilized by the Gezi
Park protests, at a meeting through mutual
friends over this past summer when I was there.
And they said to me, "Oh, the leader of the
Republican People's Party, Kemal Kilicdaroglu,
is going to be here in an hour."
I said, "OK, what are your demands?
Come on, quick.
Let's write up what your demands are."
It hadn't even dawned on them that they held
an upper hand.
So Turkey, I think, that demographic is way
behind where the Egyptians are, and they're
going to -- it's going to be a while until
they figure out the way forward.
ROSE: Very quick comment on demographics in
Korea and Poland?
NOLAND: Part of the Korean success story is
they've had the wind at their back.
They've had very good demographics for the
last 50 years or so.
Now it's going into reverse.
2010, the core productive population began
shrinking.
Next decade, dependency ratio goes up.
And if you -- you know, if you extrapolate
out current trends, 2050, the population of
the country absent Korean unification begins
falling.
What it means for the government is, is that
old people consume more services and less
manufacturers than younger people do.
And a lot of -- and services, as I mentioned,
is where the economy really lags in terms
of productivity.
And a lot of services are provided by the
state.
And so the Koreans understand they need to
get service productivity up and -- because
that is not only going to, you know, help
them in terms of dealing with these demographic
changes, but it also could be important in
terms of their fiscal position, as well.
ROSE: Quick?
ORENSTEIN: Yeah, on demographics in Poland,
a couple of points.
One is that the Solidarity movement was consonant
with a big demographic boom in Poland.
A lot of kids were born in the 1980s.
And as a result, they're a relatively young
population in Europe, but that's not going
to last.
So they, too, are going to succumb to a lot
of the declines that Europe in general has
been facing.
But that won't be until sort of 2030, approximately.
The other -- sorry, one other point to point
out here is there's a huge out-migration of
Poles in the U.K., prominently...
ROSE: All those Polish plumbers.
COOK: The Polish plumbers.
ORENSTEIN: Yes, primarily to the U.K., Ireland,
a couple other places.
And one of the big internal issues is, are
you going to have those people come back at
some point?
And if the economy keeps growing, are you
going to end up with a labor shortage and
to what extent immigration is going to occur
into Poland?
And that's a very new issue, so I don't think
we can really say much about it.
ROSE: Last quick question.
Sorry for all those -- we could talk all night
on these things.
QUESTION: Robert Warren (ph) from the Foreign
Service Institute.
Dr. Noland, would you elaborate on points
you haven't made, really, and that is on the
trade relationship.
You have Korea now, I think, as partner in
the trade -- the Trans-Pacific Partnership.
What's the meaning of this partnership?
And how might it impact on us, as well as
Korea?
NOLAND: We were just discussing this, you
know, before we came in here tonight.
The basic problem is, is that trade policy
has become salient at the domestic level and
it's become more pluralistic at the interstate
level.
And so it's hard to get things done at the
global level.
Politics abhors a vacuum, so these people
are following the path of least resistance,
which is global -- I mean, regional and plurilateral
agreements.
In Asia, you basically have two.
You have one in East Asia centered around
ASEAN.
Then you have the Trans-Pacific Partnership,
which you mentioned.
The issue with the Trans-Pacific Partnership
is most of those economies are pretty liberal
already, and they already have free trade
agreements.
I mean, we already have a free trade agreement
with South Korea.
So the marginal impact is not that great unless
you get other participants, such as Japan.
But the dynamic impact is important, because
if Korea's in, Japan is going to want to be
in.
And eventually, you're going to end up with
a situation in which the United States and
China are basically the only countries that
are not part of both of those blocks.
So if the United States and China are smart,
we would be thinking about designing those
agreements in a way that at the end of the
day they could be knitted together into one
big agreement.
Or we're going to have a situation where all
the other countries in the Asia Pacific are
freely trading with everyone else and then
we and the Chinese are the ones kind of, you
know, stuck kind of staring at each other.
ROSE: Any comments on trade in your countries?
COOK: Yeah, I think that one of the advantages
that Turkey's had over the last decade was
Turkey's rise as a trading state and the rise
of this entrepreneurial class that wanted
to trade with the world, in fact.
These traders were kind of the leading edge
of a Turkish foreign policy that really spread
its wings throughout the decade.
The question is what kind of impact that will
have -- what kind of -- the current crisis
in the political instability will have on
this -- on this class?
Where will they go?
These people were predominantly supporters
of the AKP.
This political crisis combined with this currency
crisis is just at the beginning.
I think it's unclear what's going to happen
to them.
But at least they have the infrastructure
and large numbers of people who are trading,
they have things to trade, they have advantages
in certain areas, that they could come out
on the end with no trouble whatsoever, because
that's separate -- those advantages are separate
from the political scandal that's happening
and the currency issues.
ROSE: And, Mitch, is the -- is Poland's being
part of the E.U., but not part of the eurozone
the right switch, the sweet spot?
ORENSTEIN: Oh, it certainly has been, yeah.
I mean, I would say, obviously, Poland benefits
from being part of a big and functional regional
free trade -- or regional trade agreement,
the European Union.
That's obviously a huge advantage for the
economy.
But I would say that -- I'm sort of the outlier
here, as we talked about earlier.
I think we've seen a collapse of the global
free trade regime, or the beginnings of a
collapse of the global free trade regime,
and perhaps that's because I'm looking at
it from the vantage point of Europe and not
the vantage point of Asia.
But what I see, in Poland's neck of the woods,
is that it's part of this big trade bloc called
the E.U. and it's right next to another trade
bloc that's trying to be built called the
Eurasian Union.
Notice it has the same initials, too, you
know?
And that's a real challenge for a place like
Poland.
When we see in that region of the world trade
barriers going up between those two -- now,
those are natural trading partners for Poland,
so this is why -- you know, there's the -- it's
a big deal for the E.U. to have Russia creating
a big alternative trading bloc that will have
barriers against the E.U.
So I think that Poland can react as it has
by being a Western-leaning state.
Maybe it will accentuate that, because that's
where it can trade freely, but it's an opportunity
cost.
ROSE: In a piece accompanying the package,
Ruchir Sharma talks about how the signal mark
going forward of the emerging markets will
be differentiation, that instead of thinking
of the developing world as a giant class in
which it will rise or fall as a group, you
have to look at the individual countries and
their particular circumstances and pick your
bets very carefully.
And I think that what we've heard tonight
confirms that, which is that each of these
countries has very specific histories and
very specific problems and issues.
And while there are some similarities, you
need to have -- you need to drill down on
the specifics of each country, with people
who know what they're talking about, and we've
been very fortunate, I think, to have access
to these people.
And I want to thank Marcus and Mitch and Steve
and thank all of you for coming.
And until the next FA Live.
(APPLAUSE)